Sí túnez afronta una nueva constitución
hecha a medida de su presidente caisses
ahí de eso tras ganar el Sí en el
referéndum constitucional con menos
participación en décadas De hecho no
llegó ni tan solo al 30% y la nueva
constitución fue redactada por el propio
presidente en privado y en menos de 30
días en ella se otorga poder sin
contrapeso empujando al país a un
sistema Ultra presidencialista que
podría socavar partes esenciales de la
separación de poderes y el texto se
aprobará en contra de todos los partidos
de la oposición que de hecho boicotearon
el referéndum y reemplazará al texto al
que se aprobó la asamblea Constituyente
tras la revolución de 2011 y el inicio
de la transición democrática y este
referéndum se ha celebrado en estado de
excepción hace un año el presidente
creó una decreto que le permitió
congelar el parlamento y suspender
partes muy importantes de la
Constitución hasta día de hoy una medida
que fue interpretada por muchos como un
golpe
Abre una nueva era marcada por la
inestabilidad política y también por la
certeza además en un contexto de crisis
económica donde el paro casi llega el
20% y la deuda pública ya superó el 90%